elle vous pourrez contre eric zemmour
ils sont tous repousse tous pourra par
marc a calé un par malek délégué qui a
bien fait de rester allez on va se
demander où va démarrer par aller par
vos raquettes
alors moi je suis pour la liberté
d'expression je viens d'une école très
très libérale par rapport à ça j'adore
me confronter à des personnes avec qui
charles radical d accord mais je
n'approuve pas le choix éditorial qui
est un choix qui appartient vraiment à
la chaîne proprement dite et à ses
patrons et à ses actionnaires de maître
eric zemmour à l'antenne voilà je le
prend sous cet angle là parce que c'est
pas comment dire de la censure que de
dire ça moi j'suis pas pour la censure
mais quand on a des choix qu'on a le
pouvoir de décider qui ont mené à
l'antenne ou pas moi je considère que de
mettre des personnes qui en fait
consacrent leur énergie à alimenter dans
notre pays un état d'esprit de guerre
civile parce que c'est ça eric zemmour
aujourd'hui c'est à dire qu'en fait il a
une obsession c'est toujours l'islam
c'est toujours les musulmans c'est
vraiment en fait il fait des trucs de
guerre civile en permanence et
franchement faire de l'audimat là dessus
moi je suis contre éric roger va qui
elle d'abord j'aimerais vous dire que
jamais de dire que parfois j'entendais
des leaders de la france insoumise qui
met le feu groupe ou d'une manière
systématique d'un pays également mais sa
tournée ça n'a rien à ressemer 106,6
messi messi ainsi avec la redoute non
maintenant ici à douvres dans la
raquette
alors revenons sur zemmour bah moi je
suis dans l'émission avec zemmour
christine présente cette émission on a
des débats me semble t'il intéressant et
de faux et d'ailleurs l'émission marche
très bien
moi je préfère toujours dans les débats
d'idées ne pas laisser les idées dans un
coin fermenté je préfère toujours dans
le débat les combattre ou argumenter
mais que les idées soient sur la table
pour qu'on puisse en discuter et moi
c'est dans ce sens là que j'ai fait
cette émission que je suis très honoré
de débattre avec zemmour maintenant je
veux dire une chose je n'eus on l'avait
invité ici j'ai michele acquarone
mauricie 6 mai mais je vais te dire très
simplement karim peut être que tout
aurait aimé faire cette émission honoré
peut-être que tu aurais aimé cette
émission on n'aurait pas débattre et
bien honorer un débat très bien honorer
deux débats des sas et saint honoré
engagement t'appartient aurait des bad
boys d'avant-hier appartiennent
maintenant
vous aviez invité cyril jean michel
aphatie il y à il ya quelques semaines
il a fait 1
il a fait une déclaration sur les
missions et peut-être que le synode
chose à dire qu'il - manutan m'a choqué
c'est à dire que il estime qu'il n'a pas
à débattre avec zemmour avec des mots
extrêmement durs
c'est un cochon d'idées je n'aime pas
rouler me rouler dans la fange etc moi
j'aime beaucoup jean michel aphatie
c'est un clip que je respecte moi aussi
voilà mais ce genre de propos et je
trouve que c'est pas le débat soit passé
c'est pas c'est pas la hauteur voilà
donc le débat avec m
il faut là intervient sur un sol encore
qui prend des risques aussi à la radio
et bien sûr mais bien sûr mais bien sûr
donc qu'il vienne débattre et ensuite
peut-être qu'il pourra de me sujets sont
gimme gimme
alors là il s'est passé quelque chose il
ya quinze jours 300 lits pour laisser à
eric zemmour
alors certains diront que c'est au nom
de la liberté d'expression je pense que
cela sont des hypocrites puisque c'est
une liberté d'expression à géométrie
variable qui consiste insulté toujours
les mêmes mais moi les gens que je vois
me disent mais comment si c'est qu'eric
zemmour peu sur des chaînes ne nous
insultez régulièrement nous humilier des
discours qui sont retransmis sur des
chaînes d'information où on appelle
allen on appelle à diviser les français
donc c'est une liberté d'expression à
géométrie variable puisque on interdit
dieudonné alain soral ce que je peux
comprendre pourquoi eric zemmour il a
une carte blanche
la deuxième c'est seraient ceux qui ont
un intérêt financier avec lui puisque il
travaille et je les respecte ces gens là
parce que je comprends qu'ils fassent
peut-être ma vivre d'autres personnes et
je respecte parce que le il faut payer
les factures et ce n'est pas un problème
ce qu'ils défendraient que zemmour parce
que ils font partie de leurs amis cela
me dégoûte un peu plus en revanche eric
zemmour je me suis rendu compte que plus
j'étais contre lui plus on faisait
parler de lui et en fait ce qui se passe
il n'a jamais autant fonctionné depuis
qu'on est contre lui depuis qu'on se
plaint d'eric zemmour de zineb el
rhazoui ou d'autres eh ben ils font des
cartons d'audience parce que on fait du
buzz on parle d'eux et son réinviter et
moi j'invite les gens à faire une chose
toute simple si vous êtes contre les
idées de zemmour était votre télévision
et vous verrez que les audiences
chuteront et qu'à ce moment là eric
zemmour ne sera plus mis en avant
oui m'enfin leurs employés
que dire on dirait qu'elle vient de
perdre les élections c'est vrai ça non
mais moi je pense que il y a une
autorité de régulation qui s'appelle le
csa et à la justice donc à partir du
moment où eric zemmour s'exprime si
vraiment il enfreint la loi et il ya le
csa et la justice et qu'on me l'a été
condamné en janvier où il vivait à ne
plus jamais parler
non mais c'est qu'on ne l'a plus jamais
parler alors oui mais laurence orosco
s'il vous plaît respectez les règles
vous savez qu'il ya je vous dis le nous
par exemple on a été plus menacée d'un
arrêt des missions et moi d'un harry
d'antenne que eric zemmour est ce que ça
c'est que vous mettre le curseur
pourquoi qui peut décider de qui peut
s'exprimer à la télévision en dehors du
secteur de la justice
je ne le pense pas par exemple jean luc
mélenchon a été condamné cette semaine
oui parce que pour rébellion oui c'est
quand même quelque chose de très grave
est-ce qu'on l'interdise parle à la télé
vous le demander n'ont ils vraiment
parce que non mais quelle remise des
prix non mais vous monsieur à vertou et
moi on est condamnés y en a une
interdiction mais y est un démon pour
pour rencontre exactement ce que vous
êtes pour ou contre
donc pour mais je suis pour et je les ai
toujours été évidemment suis pas
d'hélico que vous êtes en train de nous
expliquer ce qui peut vous êtes pour
parce que il n'a pas été interdit
d'antenne par les organes qui s'occupe
de ça passe il doit être non
j'aimerais savoir qui regardent les
débats au fond de moi je les regarde
tous
christine exposition est d'abord je le
regarde pour elle mais néanmoins c'est
de très grande qualité vraiment et je ne
vois pas d'autres chaînes en ce moment
qui organise des débats d'un tel niveau
bac 4 vous me disiez ça voilà que vous
lisiez parce qu'il ya quand même par
delà la mort bref et comme pour tout le
monde la question c'est pas le
personnage eric zemmour c est ce qu il
peut être à la télé ou pas oui les
suivent les chaînes privées il est sur
une chaîne a pris vite et donc
l'actionnaire a le droit de dire je
parierais mot est un peu plus sa part
amassé réussi puisque ce que me dit rick
et kiss in
messieurs cartonne oui ap vinet raison
si ça vous plaît pas vous regardez pas
oui la ligne mais on ne peut pas se
dédouaner de toute responsabilité je
suis navré la versys qu'on est en train
de faire c'est se mettre à la place des
actionnaires et des patrons de la bbc
championnat ça veut dire que cholet on
trouve au bord de l'eau et de vouloir
faire de l'argent là dessus pas d'argent
il a doublé les annoncer y a pas de pub
mais non il n'y a pas d'argent mais les
annonceurs aux médias de ce que les
allemands n'y a pas de pub dans des
missions rose à moi j'ai mis pour tout
simplement parce que je suis pour la
liberté d'expression et contrairement à
ce que dit jimmy ya rien d'hypocrites là
dedans je suis un peu d'accord avec une
nature trail sur ses news évidemment tu
vas pas dire que tu veux savoir je suis
invité je suis pas payé donc tu vois je
vais pas payer sur ses nous ici vous
êtes pays vous allez me dire que c'est
pas bien calé chronic'art et personnes
qui interviennent sur ses news
régulièrement
donc si je peux parler de du gmi pour
tout simplement parce que j'ai pas fait
en secret de l'opinion que je peux avoir
de d'eric zemmour ou même de zineb el
rhazoui pour autant je trouve qu'on ne
comprend pas les personnes on doit
combattre leur cité et offrir un espace
avec des contradicteurs en face et oui
je suis d'accord les débats sont de
qualité c'est le meilleur moyen de
combattre des idées de mettre des gens
brasse crédible capable de déconstruire
ces idées là que personnellement je
combats la seconde chose il ya deux
règles d'or c'est la loi et l'audience
la loi elle a fait ses preuves le csa
aussi peut le faire et l'audience
et c'est clair si on n'est pas content
on peut aussi zapper visiblement les
gens ont envie aussi de voir des débats
contradictoires des débats de qualité et
c'est pour ça qu'ils regardent monsieur
du mouvement pour eux je vais je vais
pleinement aller dans le sens de jimmy
sûr que moi je suis contre et comme
celle ci compte justement j'ai pas ma
télé j'ai regardé la première parce que
j'avais promis à christine et parce que
je voulais avant même de juger pouvoir
regarder la première et moi tout
simplement
maurice et la starification zemmour
zemmour et le centre de 2,2 du plateau
avec ses idées nauséabondes voit la star
célestine a les yeux la fnaim
mais malheureusement la star c'est eric
zemmour est justement starifié eric
zemmour c'est lui donner de leçons lui
donne une visibilité et lui permettent
de cartonner en librairie c'est le
permettre de lui donner une légitimité
pour aller à la convention de la droite
et déverser sa haine comme ça on est
dans un dernière se serait pierre
c'était la tipa l'interview jeudi me
suis-je dit pas l'interdire je dis juste
que moi justement je veux moi je peux
pas comme dit on ne pouvait pas de voir
ben moi je peux pas me voir eric zemmour
du coup je le regarde pas tout
simplement oui quand même alors comme
une nouvelle vraiment corps ne peut pas
vraiment je peux pas le blairer et et je
sais plus si c'est bernard ou eric tout
à l'heure qui a dit que le pays était
dans une forte tension
eric zemmour est aussi un des mecs qui
s'y dit qui permet comme ça de rallumer
les braises et qui fait que le pays est
sous tension comme ça aujourd'hui en
ayant toujours ces mêmes cibles ea on va
pas les citer encore parce que ce serait
encore lui donner de la visibilité de la
visibilité pardon et de la pub pour moi
tout simplement
je ne rejoins pas matin pour regarder
l'eczéma quand même voulu distinguer la
parole à christina ericsson distinguer
deux choses dans la question être êtes
vous pour ou contre aisément dans les
médias moi je réponds pour parce que je
pense qu'il y a des gens qui pensent
comme eric zemmour et je me dis que au
nom de quoi on devrait interdire cette
pratique est dans le pays en revanche si
on avait posé la question êtes vous pour
une présence quotidienne des risées me
rend l'antenne j'aurais dit non d'accord
et je fais la distinction entre une
place dans les médias
un courant de pensée qui existent dans
le pays et en une
j'ai envie de dire vitrine de qu'on
pourrait donner à quelqu'un
effectivement il ya des idées qui me
semble plutôt anti républicaine quand je
dis quand je dis que je suis pour
c'est comme si je disais est ce que si
les électeurs le souhaitent
vous êtes pourquier des députés du front
national à l'assemblée nationale
si les électeurs le souhaite on va pas
interdire à ce qu'il en est en revanche
est ce que je suis pour que le front
national sont majoritaires à l'assemblée
la réponse est non évidemment mais je
pense qu'il faut faire une distinction
entre les missions quotidiennes
la présence quotidienne d'eric zemmour
autour de qui tout tourne effectivement
une place dans les médias qui doit
effectivement existé parce qu'on doit
penser différemment et on a le droit
effectivement
ne pas être d'accord avec lui les bras
ce qui m'a le regard alors on va on va
voir la vie je vais rajouter cinq
minutes qu'on va voir la vie quand même
de christine et de éric ce que vous
travaillez avec lui au quotidien on va
se retrouver donc dans un instant avec
eric kristy les roues contre zemmour
dans les médias alors on a déjà fait dix
minutes de débat mais on demande 10
minutes de plus parce que c'est vrai que
on aimerait entendre
mine de rien eric naulleau et christine
kelly là dessus alors eric naulleau vous
donc bien sûr vous êtes pour eric
zemmour dans les médias travail est cuit
depuis combien de temps maintenant
puis une 12 ans je crois 12 ans 12 ou 13
ans d'accord vous êtes pour ou hilla il
ya beaucoup changé depuis 12 ans non non
pas pas énormément ça y est humainement
il est resté le même après je trouve que
c'est quelqu'un qui s'est radicalisée
dans sa pensée
d'ailleurs je crois que la france s'est
radicalisée aussi on se rend pas compte
parce que c'est un mouvement très voilà
continuer est lent mais je les français
sont beaucoup plus radicalisés sur
certains sujets et zemmour est à
l'unisson moi aujourd'hui dire que je
suis un peu préoccupé par la tournure
des débats parce qu'on a commencé par
pour ou contre hanouna maintenant c'est
plutôt contre zemmour je vais finir par
me retrouver au chômage
je voudrais que ça cesse hanouna zemmour
ses deux salles deux ambiances
absolument non mais vraiment et on
risque pas de vous confondre ensuite
j'observe que c'est dès que je suis que
je suis pas là que je le quitte des yeux
qui s'embrouillent ça se passe plutôt
bien chez zemmour et naulleau je vois
une brouille ailleurs après plus
sérieusement moi ma position n'a jamais
varié zemmour représente un courant
d'opinion contrairement à ce qui était
dit dans le sujet la dame je sais plus
qui s'était disait je suis choqué de la
place qu'on lui donne on ne va pas
donner de place cette personne n'a
jamais mis un revolver sur la tempe de
personne pour acheter un livre de
zemmour ou pour regarder une émission à
laquelle participent zemmour il fait de
l'audimat il fait des ventes en
librairie
des gens se reconnaissent en lui il faut
savoir le respecter ensuite j'ai pas
bien compris
j'ai pas bien compris la sortie de jimmy
tout à l'heure il se trouve que moi je
suis ami avec ses mots et je regrette
c'est je ne suis pas un robot je ne peux
pas me dépouiller de tout affect pour
vous donner une opinion qui serait
complètement comme sa froide des tâches
et l'amitié que je lui porte compliquent
en effet mon jugement mais je le
reconnais je pourrais vous dire non je
vais vous donner mon avis objectif
je manque peut-être d'objectivité parce
que c'est quelqu'un que j'aime bien
humainement
ensuite deuxième contradiction pour
jimmy
n'a pas carte blanche le csa intervient
très régulièrement la chaîne ces news a
demandé que ce soit en différé désormais
les débats et l'a obtenu c'est quelqu'un
qui est sous contrôle des autorités et
qui est aussi tout le temps confrontés à
un contradicteur je trouve que je suis
le plus ancien le contradicteur
historique mais je n'ai jamais vu sauf
dans la convention de la droite zemo en
roue libre mais je ne vois pas en quoi
il est un scandale démocratique où un
scandale audiovisuelle le scandale c'est
qu'il qu'il parle tout seul
après je moi je lui dit en privé je lui
dis en public parfois il sorte de
gigantesque conneries ce qu'on a vu tout
à l'heure sur le général bugeaud je lui
dis c'est qu'une des gigantesques
connerie de dire ça et de le dire dans
ces termes
personne ne peut l'accepter et il a été
le premier à le reconnaître
voilà c'est plus qu'une au cornouaille
l'impression que le sait c'est plus sur
vos côtés avoue cyril et qu'on attend le
moindre dérapage en touche pas en poste
comme s'ils avaient un screen pour
savoir est ce que quelqu'un va péter de
travers pour en faire une affaire d'état
alors ça arrive parce que c'est vrai
plus que sur eric zemmour et moi je
pense que ce n'est pas parce que les
éric des idées d'eric zemmour existent
dans la société qu'il faut lui donner un
os alors l'heure pour les diffuser alors
je le distribue des métastases petit à
petit dans la tête des gens car et
balance de trois références historiques
mélanger au quel bel orateur il a un
talent évident et donc dans la tête des
gens l'idée bah oui la vérité sort de la
bouche de justice n'a pas besoin juste
pour dire aussi alors pour prendre la
défense au lait c'est rare la défense du
csa c'est vrai que voilà même si eric
zemmour marche très bien et fait 200
mille téléspectateurs
quand tu es pmp ont fait entre 1
millions 3,1 millions de singles en cas
d'excès iso un avertissement
c'est vrai qu'à part diffusé à zidane il
a comparé voilà une mise en garde sévère
mise en fin à leur a dit attention qui
n'a pas un canular qui n'a pas existé
qu'il faut qu'ils étaient montés voilà
il va rien d'homophobe dans l'histoire
il vous avez pris des millions d'euros
d'amendé mais sur l'engin fille voilà
donc juste il a été condamné je viens
d'apprendre qu'il était de nouveau
convoquée au tribunal c'est pas
quelqu'un qui se baladent et qui peut
dire ce qu'il veut quand ils dépassent
les règles de la loi toubon dans ce pays
on est dans un pays où la légalité
compte on est dans un état de droit et
l'état de droit s'applique aussi à eric
zemmour
alors je me tourne et christine kristin
alors on va on va revenir sur sur ce qui
s'est passé c'est vrai que vous
christine un moment la direction vous
appelez vous aviez ce que vous acceptez
de prendre cette tranche de reprendre
cette tranche qui était à l'agonie en
audience on va pas se mentir on parle on
dit la vraie vérité aux téléspectateurs
cette tranche marché très mal c'est une
tranche très importante pour une chaîne
d'info
voilà parce que c'est vrai que c'est
aussi une locomotive pour les chaînes
d'info et mine de rien même s'il n'y a
pas de pub eric revel il ya la moyenne
journée qui fait que quand vous faites
des grosses audiences
mine de rien en moyenne journée et ben
vous pouvez afficher une moyenne qui est
plus haute
voilà je vous le dis ce qui se passait
chez explique aux téléspectateurs c'est
comme nous il ya des pmp
voilà qui est la locomotive de deux de
ses huit mais derrière on regarde tous
les jours la moyenne de la chaîne sur
toute la journée
aujourd'hui eric zemmour et vous
christine vous êtes une locomotive pour
la chaîne et donc la chaîne vous appelez
et vous a dit voilà on aimerait que tu
sois donc là la journaliste qui permet
de faire ce qu'ils permettent de faire
cette émission tous les jours avec eric
zemmour est un contradicteur
je sais que vous avez longuement
réfléchi christine aujourd'hui moi la
question qui va vous poser est ce que
vous regrettez un instant au pas du tout
parce que on sait christine à leur
courage incroyable aujourd'hui christine
c'est quelqu'un qui ne partage pas du
tout les idées d'eric zemmour voilà je
le sais et je suis bien placé pour
savoir ce que ce qu'est ce qui n'est
vraiment une amie très proche
voilà on était encore hier soir ensemble
jusqu'à pas d'heure c'est vrai et ça m'a
aidé à me christine voilà je le dis et
c'est vrai que christine je crois savoir
que l on souffre beaucoup de voix là de
ça parce que moi je vois ce qui se passe
sur les réseaux sociaux
vous avez beaucoup de menaces moi ça m'a
beaucoup affecté aussi pour vous parce
que vous êtes une amie
aujourd'hui est-ce que ce que vous
regrettez ou pas du tout premièrement je
suis très émue que vous soyez ému c'est
que je me sens très émue et parce que
vous avez été le premier à m'appeler
lorsque j'ai parlé des menaces te ment
et je tiens à vous remercier
personnellement personne ne le sait vous
avez été le premier à m'appeler deuxième
personne à m'appeler marlène schiappa la
remercie de m'avoir appelé elle est avec
moi mais je vous entends très émue et et
franchement les soutiens que j'ai reçus
à ce moment là m'ont vraiment permis de
tenir parce que et j'ai reçu aussi
de la part du président la république
parce que beaucoup de d'associations
envoyé un courrier au président de la
république en demandant effectivement
que pour la liberté de la presse on ne
peut pas attaquer menacé de mort une
journaliste qui fait son métier
j'ai reçu un sms du président la
république et je tiens aussi à le
remercier pour ce soutien pour la
liberté de la presse et pour on puisse
pas attaquer un journaliste à part ça ça
m'a permis de tenir parce que je me suis
posé la question est-ce que si je suis
boulanger et qu' il ya quelqu'un qui
vient acheter mon pain et que je
n'apprécie pas forcément est-ce que je
vais refuser lui vendre si je suis un
chauffeur de taxi est quelqu'un que je
n'apprécie pas forcément monte dans mon
taxi est ce que je vais dire de
descendre est-ce que je vais refuser de
vendre à quelqu'un etc
non je suis journaliste je trouve que je
suis engagé dans la liberté d'expression
et je ne regrette
à aucun instant d'avoir accepté cette
proposition sur le fond 36 émissions
parlées de poutine parler de trump
parler de l'idéologie l'avenir
idéologique de la france par l'est de
l'europe parlait de l'europe parlait de
l'otan parler des retraites va là les
sujets qu'on aborde au au quotidien et
effectivement jamais en roue libre avec
différents d'éditorialistes dont eric
revel ou bien eric de riedmatten marc
menant voilà qui sont là impôts qu on
puisse débattre et avec aussi un
contradicteur tous les soirs comme ce
soit en éveil n'est que là-bas vraie vie
était vraiment exceptionnel c'est
intéressant de voir et on est interpellé
de voir la puissante de l'audience sur
toute la chaîne par rapport à cette
émission et je pense pour avoir été au
csa que quelque part on se dit que le
téléspectateur avait soif d'avoir une
petite antenne différentes une vision de
la vie différente
qu'on soit d'accord ou pas parce que les
gens qui m'écrivent jeunes aux plus
beaux coins il ya maintenant avec les
menaces de mort c'est quelqu'un d'autre
qui joue mais les gens qui écrivent
disent que qu'on soit d'accord ou pas
avec ces mots on regarde on écoute on
critique et le dernier mot que je dirais
là dessus c'est qu'il faut pas prendre
les téléspectateurs pour un imbécile
c'est pas parce qu'il va entendre
quelqu'un à la télévision dire manger
des pommes qu'ils vont manger des pommes
c'est pas parce qu'il entend quelqu'un
la télévision dit
je n'aime pas quelque chose qui vont pas
aimer ils vont réfléchir et je trouve
que prendre nos téléspectateurs pour
quelqu'un d'intelligent qui est capable
de jugement c'est une avancée dans ce
pays de donner la liberté d'expression
libre abrite aux téléspectateurs celui
de regarder d'écouter de juger ou
d'états non merci écrit-il alors
christine juste je sais que vous ne
partagez pas du tout les idées d'eric
zemmour quand raquel dit voilà c'est
fait pour faire de l'audience
c'est à des fins économiques qu'est ce
que vous répondez à ça moi je dis que de
deux choses l'une
un patron de chaîne par exemple il
réfléchit a effectivement il veut faire
de l'audience
est-ce qu'on peut le lui reprocher pour
faire de l'audience
on peut faire des choses qui sont
complètement strictement interdite à la
vision à la télévision ce qui est fait
n'est pas interdit à la télévision
il ya beaucoup de choses qui sont
interdites en france à la télévision ça
ce n'est pas interdit est donc si on la
chaîne veut faire de l'audience et son
choix si le téléspectateur
ils ne font pas d'audience et que le
téléspectateur a décidé de ne pas
regarder donc ça effectivement c'est le
choix de quelqu'un de se dire oui ils
ont décidé de faire de l'audience ou pas
mais bon moi je trouve que comme disait
aussi rose ameziane que la l'audience
c'est quelque chose on ne fait pas de
l'audience avec n'importe quoi attention
faire une audience en faisant des appels
à la haine
je serai la première à dire non
d'ailleurs ça n'aurait pas été possible
et on serait sanctionné immédiatement
par le csa qui regarde toutes les
émissions mais ce qui s'est passé sur
lci comme l'a dit me mine de rien
c'était un petit peu sur lci c'était en
est libre très léger comme louis saha
était très léger en général va se
retrouver sur le général bugeaud
on a une mise en demeure on est en
différé depuis c'était quand les
émissions
direct on a fait 30 ses émissions 8 en
direct et en différé en différé et ses
news a saisi le conseil d'état parce que
plusieurs fois le conseil d'état annulé
des décisions par rapport aux propos
d'eric zemmour on va regarder ce qu'on
pensait téléspectateurs eric zemmour
dans les médias pour à 45% contre à 55%
oui c'est quand même ouais c'est assez
partagés c'est plus de ses plus contre
c'est et c'est assez incroyable